[Music]
that one was the best we've done ballet
baby we are here at the Los Angeles
finally do what you have been asking for
for years there is a reason we have not
done it this is impossible my sister is
a ballerina she did dance ever since she
was four years old and so I've picked
her up from practices so I kind of get
the lingo I went to a school of theater
and dance I'm the only try guy with a
dance diploma college-educated
[ __ ] I did not take a dance
class I have a stupid Benjamin Button
old man baby body I am the most brittle
and flexible man that has ever lived
I'm not ballet trained at all I'm
actually only pretty great in the
hip-hop realm so I'm going into this as
fresh as the other guys we're gonna be
graceful we're gonna be poised and we're
gonna fall on our bodies your fault you
wanted this you're requested this video
when I haven't painted this your fault
Leslie
[Music]
my name is Bianca Buell I'm principal
dancer with the Los Angeles ballet that
means you're one of the best ones I'm
actually the only principal dancer so I
need you to you guys are going to learn
a few ballet routines and then finally
you'll get to perform them on stage so
we're gonna be training with seasoned
professionals young ones we have first
position our heels are touching out
neither squeeze together your bottom is
also squeeze you're lifting up and your
toes are turned out as far as it
possibly can be without being behind you
now good
second position you tendu um reaches to
the side of your foots distance away
what that's right
third position is run it from the top I
don't know how I can do it I just can
thank you how long have you both been
dancing seven years well I thought you
guys were seven that 70% of your life
has been playing we usually start young
just because it is such an intricate
thing to learn and to form your joints
I'm sorry what side do fit as her
growing you want your joints to be open
and your feet to be flexible because so
you're like beautiful dance mutants I
was gonna say mutants I'm not allowed to
sit down I just got yelled at by a
ten-year-old for sitting there not
allowed to sit in valet because it's not
proper I hate everything about this
they're lovely children miss the cool
part this part is pretty cool too
about this Exodus you're doing really
well it's just those two need a little
warm-up with bar so we're ready for
center and we're gonna do a couple of
exercises across the floor so you step
out and you pique and side again pique
and static pique and side again how do
you not get super dizzy you use your
spot so we spot him okay I didn't do
that is it a good idea at age 30 as a
male to start trying to open your joints
great let's do it wait that's just the
warmup that's just yeah good question do
you sleep in a giant music box I do not
you're wearing pointe shoes now oh my
god Wow
so you crunch up your toes and you're
like you're on like your knuckle no
you're actually dead on the tippy toes
how do your toenails not fall off they
do do professionals get hurt
the after gosh must get hurt all the
time
I got toe cramp yes what are you doing
it's hurting you underneath it all but
we're trying to make it look beautiful
on top how much fried chicken would you
say you eat in a week I hate fried
chicken sorry can you demonstrate a few
classic point moves right so this is a
soothe you and then we can go to the
posse and we can do a little
my second thing in French history
it's effortlessly graceful well you guys
can try if you're like I can't get in
there baby then you got it in I got I
have a tiny foot I have the answer feet
I don't want to do this I know I don't
think I don't think I can
oh boy now try and straighten your knee
are you talking about I know but that's
why I'm whispering I don't want to do
this him gotta hurt myself a week - are
we gonna hurt ourselves I hope not
well I do feel like my ankles about the
snap stretch down stretch well this was
too awful thank you for sharing let's
get to the routine yeah so now we're
gonna do a condensed version of waltz of
the flowers great so we're on our knee
there's four walks pom pom pom pom pom
pom at day weekends with rehearsals for
the valleys that we're performing so
that might be two or three or just the
one if it's a full-length piece this
sort of feels like we're doing a limp
Jesus right just gonna be still for that
we're a house that until 4:30 in the
afternoon and we go home and recover and
I eat and do it again the next day
sooner wait I
I sell buddies we get a lot of injuries
or it's your ice budget like a lot seven
is it fair to say that if you keep a
good face and move the hands people
won't pay attention to the feet could be
we are actually really trying it just
looks like the paradeen moves because we
suck
exactly oh I only did hip-hop dancing
[Music]
this is exhausting me fully I'm done I'm
wrecked
already we put on some tutus for you
[Music]
this mean we're in the Los Angeles
ballet thank you so much for getting us
in that's incredible I totally
understand the appeal of tutus now cuz
all I want to do is try the routine
again with this moving yeah
[Music]
it's like you do all these homecare
moves and then you also have to look
graceful
[Music]
it's about like which leg is doing what
and then you're trying to keep your arms
in your torso from looking dumb it's
very little and yet it's so much
my glasses totally snapped and broke
ballet too hard and my glasses broke
we're gonna learn the Russian dance
which is a male dance full of tricks fun
exciting things big jumps and turns
flying across the floor it's gonna be
too hard it's gonna be hard it's gonna
be very different from the waltz of the
flowers it's not chakra in the movement
you don't have to be flow and stuff it's
almost better to look like you're really
putting your effort into it you're gonna
touch your toes both in the air so you
go down to the personal journey in
you're constantly trying to be perfect
like Black Swan
nor am I not gonna become a beautiful
bird person at the end of this so what
happens at the end of Black Swan yeah
she's not seen comes in did you know
movie something much darker happen it's
a device
and one two three
shanky is like straight this is easily
the hardest dance we've ever done I'm
the most tired I've ever been I thought
I wasn't shape but I'm not this is a
pure exhaustion of every joint I think
this might be the first time in a try
guys video where people say that really
sucked Bianca what is your final words
of advice for us just give it your all
you gave it a really good really good go
all right guys let's head to the stage
elegant wipe so elegant that's really
your wife all right so here we are a
couple of weeks after our rehearsal with
Bianca and the LA ballet
I can guarantee that there's no way that
we can take this you are gonna see every
single fault net basically has very
little rhythm hopefully everyone's just
distracted by my roguish good looks and
fierce condor zach has is it cool
disorders that prevent him from moving
properly you're like I'm going to
disgrace the arc more and Keith is a
gangly giant klutz I think the Russian
dance is too hard
but you know our current relationship
with Russia isn't that great so I think
that's okay I really don't want to pay
respect to Russia I'd rather not do it
right all right Gollum Moretz we go back
and do a nutcracker yes all is not sound
three one two three
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
almost that was really really hard yeah
the men's dance is so athletic it's like
we're doing the jump so much can we put
on low to tooth
how do you feel okay I stuff I'm a
planner monster do like a 50s librarian
housewife
you have mix that there is such a
bitchen makeup I look like the popular
girl yeah we hate you that's amber she
has problem hmm I definitely hear she's
also good oh my god you are so pretty
much about the discipline of ballet they
never talk about the fun you [ __ ]
have fun
[Music]
I consider myself someone who can dance
but ballet is on a whole nother
stratosphere so much respect to other
Valerie is out there is u-haul are much
tougher than any other expert that we've
ever come across with your legs facing
this way you have to be a spider human
and then be graceful with your spider
body the first thing I want to do is
call my sister right now because I kind
of understand what she had to go through
bed legs hurt I tried to go upstairs
earlier and I screamed ballerinas are
super humans they make it look so
graceful and they are masking pain if
you ever run into a ballerina just start
throwing to them I'm actually really
proud of the other try guys because as
bad of a dancers that they can be they
gave it their all even though no one can
do ballet unless you're professional you
can at least gain an appreciation for
watching we tried and got hurt a lot
instead thanks a lot everybody thanks
for suggesting this Internet it was too
hard [ __ ] you welcome Carly I'm Madison
it's a pleasure to have you here this is
Amber hi amber I'm deaf in one ear
okay factory dildo rejects let's get
into position what
she's my best friend no I'm not
Carly are you gonna be best friend I
hope so let's start the music before it
died
oh no I can't hear the music expert here
I can't hear that news